مرحبا بكم حلب لم تعد تشبه نفسها في شيء
المدينه الضاربه بثها الحضري العريق في
التاريخ تحولت على يد النظام السوري الى
دمار واسع تزهق مئات الارواح بين جدرانه
المتهاوي بفعل القصف اليومي بشتى انواع
الاسلحه لمدنيين ذنبهم انهم وجدوا انفسهم
رهينه كماشه القتال بين الاسد
ومعارضيه مشهد دامن يتابع المجتمع الدولي
فصوله الماساويه مكتفيا بالتنديد في احسن
الاحوال دون ان يقدم على اي خطوه جديه
توقف المحرقه التي اتت على الاخضر واليابس
وشملت البشر قبل الحجر مدمره في طريقها
معالم عمرانيه لا تقدر بثمن حلب بين الامس
واليوم في التقرير
التالي حلب قبل قرن من الزمان شتان ما بين
ماضيها الزاهر وحاضرها المعلم قيل في هذا
يوم لو الف الم سفرا عن مفاخره لراح يكتب
في عنوانه
حلبا المدينه عاصرت روما وبابل ودمشق
ونينوى بعد ان كتبت سيره الانسانيه الاولى
هي اقدم المدن الماهوله في العالم منذ
تاسيسها قبل الميلاد بعشره الاف عام ضربت
في الجذور حضاره وتاريخا وازدهارا وامتطى
على مر سنيها ظهر العصور حتى قيل ان ابا
الانبياء ابراهيم عليه السلام مر بها
ويشهد له مسجد في قلعتها حتى اليوم تربعت
على طريق الحرير لتكون محور التجاره
العالميه الذي جسد ازدهار العديد من
الحضارات في اصقاع
العالم كانت اهم حاضره اقتصاديه في الدوله
العثمانيه باكبر سوق مسقوف عرفه العالم
انذاك احتفظت حلب الشهباء رغم ما مر بها
من غزو اخطره ما قام به المغول الذين
هدموا كثيرا من معالمها احتفظت برونقها
وطابعها التاريخي المميز بعد ان اعيد
ترميمها لتظل بواباتها واسوارها وخاناتها
تحدث عن عراقه لا تخفى في العصر الحديث
عانت المدينه تجاهلا وتهميشا طويلين من
السلطه المركزيه في دمشق ومورست في حقها
سياسات عمقت الهوه بين مختلف مكوناتها على
اساس المصالح والولاءات وهو النهج الذي
برع فيه حافظ الاسد واستكمله ابنه بشار
بتقسيم حلب الى شرقيه
[موسيقى]
وغربيه لم يمعن النظام في التدمير الممنهج
وسياسه الارض المحروقه في حلب فحسب وانما
دعا حلفائه من قوات روسيه وايرانيه ومن
ميليشيات طائفيه عراقيه ولبنانيه دعاهم
للاحتفال على جثث القتلى ودمار لم يبق
حجرا على
حجر معالم حلب رويدا رويدا مساجدها
واسواقها احياؤها وبواباتها لقد اضحت
المدينه الاكثر دمارا وخرابا منذ نهايه
الحرب العالميه
الثانيه انها مدينه الكواكب صاحب كتاب
طبائع الاستبداد وما كان يعلم انها ستدفع
ولو بعد اكثر من قرن اغزر الدماء في
مواجهه اعتى
استبداد
وهي مدينه المتنبي ومدينه ابي فراس
الحمداني وكانها تتمثل اليوم بيته وقال
اصيحابي الفرار او الردا فقلته امران
احلاهما
مر حلب اليوم بين فرار من خلال اتفاق يملى
على ثوارها او يباد ما بقي
من معنا في الاستديو الدكتور شمس الدين
الكيلاني الباحث في المركز العربي للابحاث
ودراسه السياسات بالدوحه ومن الرياض ينضم
الينا الدكتور رياض نعسان اغا وزير
الثقافه السوري الاسبق والمتحدث باسم
الهيئه العليا للمفاوضات وابدا معك دكتور
رياض نعسان
اغا دكتور عديده هي المحطات التاريخيه
التي دمرت فيها حلب نتيجه غزوات و حروب
لكن اليوم بماذا تتميز عن غيرها هذه الحرب
التي تدور رحاها على ارض
حلب اولا مفجع هذا الفيلم الذي
قدمتموه وفي الحقيقه هو بعض يسير من
الماسات الكبرى التي تعاني منها حلب واذا
اردنا ان نتذكر دمارات حلب عبر التاريخ
ربما نجد هذا الدمار لاول مره يحدث ممن
يسمون انفسهم سوريين من اهل البلد يعني
عندما تقول ان التتار هدموا حلب وحاصروها
و تمكنوا في بعض المراحل التاريخيه من هدم
اسوار قلعتها الشهيره فانهم قادمون من
اعماق اسيا اما الذين يدمرون حلب بالاساس
الذين سيحملون المس مسؤوليه التاريخيه هم
للاسف هم الذين كانت مهمتهم ان يحموا حلب
وان يدافعوا عن شعبها لا ان يحاصرها ويجوع
اهلها ويدمرها ويقتلوهم وحلب هذه المدينه
العظيمه تصمد وهي الان بعد حصار طويل وبعد
عناء
خطير طيب في ظل في ظل التناقض
امام البشريه كلها طيب في في ظل التناقض
الواضح على
المستوى السياسي وايضا على مستوى
الخيارات ما بين المتقاتلين الان هل يمكن
القول انه كان
بالامكان تجنيب حلب او تفادي معركه حلب
مثلا يعني طبعا تعلم بان كلمه لو هذه يعني
لا فائده منها الان طبعا كان بالامكان
تجنيب سوريا كلها هذا الدمار لو ان النظام
استجاب ولو الى حد ادنى من متطلبات الشعب
وانتم في الجزيره تابعتم تفاصيل هذا
الدمار منذ ست سنوات الى الان كان
بالامكان انلا يحدث شيء لان الشعب السوري
بقي سته سته اشهر وربما ثمانيه اشهر لا
يحمل سلاحا وانما جر جرا الى التسليح وكان
بالامكان لو انه منذ اللحظات الاولى لقيت
طلبات الشعب بالحريه والديمقراطيه وبالاصح
لقيت استجابه ولا سما انتم تعلمون بان
الناس عندما خرجوا متاثرين بثورات الربيع
العربي كما سمي انذاك خرجوا يطالبون
باصلاح النظام وانا كنت شاهد عصر على ذلك
كنت شاهدا على كل التفاصيل نعرف بان الناس
لم ينادوا باسقاط النظام وهذا الامر انسحب
على مدن عديده يعني انت تتحدث الان الان
عن حلب ولكن قبل ذلك كنا نتابع دمار حمص
المدينه التاريخيه العظيمه ايضا ودمار
الارياف السوريه
وبالتالي تعرضت ايضا مدن كبيره مهمه الرقه
دير الزور درعا ادلب كل هذه المدن هي
سوريا و ولعل الدمار الحاصله الان يشكل
ذروه غير مسبوقه حتى في دمار ستالين جراد
لكن الغريب يعني كل هذه المدن الحديثه
الان عن حلب بشكل اكبر دكتور كيلاني لماذا
تعتبر حلب في كل الحروب التي شنت عليها
تعتبر انها الفيصل الاهم في اي معركه او
في مسار هذه الحروب خصوصا اليوم مثلا
عندما يقال ان منعطفا جديدا في الازمه
السوريه سيكون فيما لو حسمت معركه حلب
يعني حلب لما كانان تداخل سوريه حتى دا
داخل المحيط
ام مدينه ل قيمتها على مستوى الحضاري
الثقافي اللي حكى عنه
الدكتور على مستوى العمران على مستوى
التصنيع الصناعه السوريه موجوده بحلب
التجاره بلد التجاره على مستوى كان
العالمي لانه على خطوط التجاره
الحرير العاصمه الثالثه كانت البلد الثالث
كانت في الامبراطوريه العثمانيه بعد
اسطنبول
والقاهره حلب مو بعدين حلب في لها صيلات
عميقه كانتت بالعراق هي توام توام الموصل
ام والان المصادفه المرعبه انه الموصل نفس
ال عمليه يؤخذ رائع يعني هو الموضوع
تاريخي ام جغرافي هنا ل لمدينه حلب حلب مك
انت كبشر يعني حلب 5 ملايين
نسمه يعني هي ودمشق على مستوى سكاني
تقريبا مثل بعضهم اذا كان في ما في تفوق ل
ل حلب
امم ف
ما هي مدينه بس صنعت الجغرافيا او الكذا
انجازها
ومكانتها وشج شعبها واثارتها مع ه النظام
من سنه 80 دمر دمر حارات بالنظام طيب اي
في ناحيه ح شغله حده نحت ما عم تجابه اي
طرف ما مين عم يجابه حلب مو المغول
نفس المساله
الغرباء النظام غريب عن بلد بلد مجموعه
احتلت البلد عمليا واتى مع جحافل الطائفيه
على مستوى قاره اسيا طيب افغانستان
باكستان وبذلك وراهم الميليشيا الطائفيه
الايرانيه ميليشيا حزب الله كل الحاقدين
الطائفيين اللي عندهم حقد طائفي على بلاد
الشام كب الشام الان يقاتلون حلب طيب
دكتور رياض يعني ربما يقال اي ان الحديث
عما تخسره حلب وخسرته من تراثها وتاريخها
وعمارتها القديمه انما هو الان ترف ثقافي
قياسا لتلك الخسائر البشريه الكبرى التي
تمنى بها حلب وسكانها ما
رايك يعني بالتاكيد الانسان اغلى ما في
الكون كله هذا امر لا جدل فيه قطره من دم
طفل تساوي عندنا الكثير لان كل الكون في
خدمه الانسان ولذلك لا نستطيع ان نفاضل
بين الحجر والبشر لكن بعض الحجر هو وجدان
البشر يعني انت عندما تحدث حلبي ما الان
مشرد او نازح او مهاجر فتحكي له عن سوق
حلب الذي دمر عن قلعه حلب التي يعني
عمليا يعجب المر كيف يجرؤ جندي سوري على
ان يوجه بندقيته او مدفعه نحوها او عن اي
اثر من اثار حلب العظيمه عن خاناتها
العظيمه التي فيها ذاكره البشريه ايه
طبيعي ان تجد ان ال الموقف مثير ومرعب
طبعا بالتاكيد انا افضل البشر على الحجر
ولكن اؤكد بان هذا الحجر ليس حجرا عاديا
انت عندما تتحدث عن حلب تتحدث عن
مدينه يقر العالم كله وهي مدينه مسجله في
اليونسكو من التراث العالمي يقر بانها
اقدم مدينه ماهوله على وجه الارض ام طبعا
تنافسها في ذلك تنافسها دمشق في القدم
وتنافسها اريحا في فلسطين ولكن نحن في
تراثنا الثقافي نسيطر معرفيا على تاريخ
15000 عام ولو اننا نتابع مزيدا من
الابحاث سنجد اننا قد نجد الى ابعد من 15
عام 15000 عام اخرين وبالتالي انت امام
تراث ليس لنا وحدنا هذا تراث للانسانيه
كلها ولا تستطيع ان تصف حلب بحضاره واحده
حلب حضارات عظيمه عندما تتكلم عن الثقافه
الهلنستيه ستجد حلب عندما تتكلم عن يمحاض
المملكه العظيمه ستجد حلب عندما تتكلم عن
اطراف مملكه ابلا ستجد حلب عندما تتكلم عن
تاريخ الاراميه والسريانيه وعن الثقافات
الهلنستيه كلها و وحلب مجمع شعوب يعني حلب
التي فتحت قلبها لكل شعوب العالم قدمت على
مدى قرون نموذج التعايش بين الشعوب وبين
الثقافات طيب امام كل ذلك واهميه حلب كيف
تعاطى
العالم مع هذه المعركه الاخيره مشاهدينا
ستيفن دي مستوره مبعوث الامم المتحده
الخاص الى سوريا قال انه يامل في تجنيب
حلب ما وصفها بالمعركه الرهيبه واضاف دي
مستوره انه توقع ان تكون المعركه رهيبه
تنتهي بحلول احتفالات عيد الميلاد وراس
السنه وعبر عن امله في الا تقع المعركه
وان تكون هناك صيغه ما سيد الكيلاني ما
رايك بهذا الموقف لدي مستوره يعني حتى
الان المعركه الرهيبه لم تقع ربما يامل ان
تكون صيغه ما لحل الموضوع بال بالمحفل
الاعدام لحلب ما راح اجيب ذكر د مستوره
نهائيا لانه احد الشهود واحد القضاه اللي
دمروا حلب
صاروا من وقت اللعين في الامم المتحده
قضيته قضيه حكايا وسوالف وقصص واجتماعات
مع النظام ومع العراق مع روسيا ومع ايران
شو عمل دمست دوم ستورا عقل غربي لا يفهم
من مشكله سوريه الا في هناك ارهابيين لازم
يقضوا عليهم فقط لا غير هذا د مستوره هذا
عقله هذا عقله مثل عقل اي واحد غربي عنصري
كامل حلب اللي صار بحلب
يذكر او بده يذكرنا بالمستقبل انه العالم
رجع للقرن التاس عشر كل الانجازات اللي
حققت البشريه بالقرن الع
وزلت من خلال التجربه السوريه ازيلت لانه
اللي عم يصير
بسوريا ما بقى في قانون دولي ما بقى في
قانون
انساني كل الضوابط الاخلاقيه والانسانيه
اللي رعتها الامم المتحده والعالم خلال
الحروب العالميه الاولى والثانيه
وحرب ف ازيلت عن الوجود ما بقى في الا ما
بقى لا في الا قاضي ولا في الا حاكم كان
في امريكا تعتبر هي قاد قاده النظام
العالمي ازيلت القيم الحضاريه تقصد بهذا
بهذا ماضل حامي حتى قيم موجوده بس ما في
الا حامي ما في الا منظمات تحميه
لاحظ دكتور رياض ما شهدته حلب من دمار هل
يمكن وضعه في
اطار نتيجه الطبيعيه لحرب المدن ام يمكن
اعتباره سياسه ممنهجه
ومقصوده يعني للاسف تحدث الاخ الفاضل
الاستاذ كيلاني عن ما سماه الحقد التاريخي
يعني انت لابد ان تتساءل ما سر هذا الجنون
الفارسي الايراني لحجز 70,000 عسكري
ايراني ياتون فض فضلا عن الميليشيات
القادمه من لبنان وهي ميليشيات ارهابيه
مثل حزب الله تلك القادمه من العراق
والقادمه من لمام شتات افغانستان وباكستان
من الشيعه تتساءل ما سر ذلك وما الذي
يدفعهم الى هذا اليوم والبارحه تم حجد
جديد من الايرانيين طبعا بوسعك ان تفهم ان
روسيا تبحث عن مكان وان هذا المكان تريده
على حساب دماء الاطفال وهذا ما نح نمل
روسيا مسؤوليه كبرى تاريخيا عنه وبالتالي
نحمل الولايات المتحده ايضا لان اداره
اوباما في تهاونها هي التي اوصلتنا الى
هذا الحال وايضا نتساءل عن دور الاتحاد
الاوروبي الاتحاد الاوروبي الذي يعتبر حلب
بوابه لاوروبا وبالتالي كانت عبر التاريخ
الانساني كله هي صله الوصل التاريخي بين
الشرق والغرب نحمل ضمير الانسانيه جميعا
هذا الذي يحدث ويقال بان هناك مئتا ارهاب
هكذا يقول دمست واختلف في العدد بداه ب
900 ثم نزل الى 200 من اجل 200 رجل
تسمونهم ارهابيين وليكونوا ارهابيين من
اجل متي شخص نهدم مدينه عظيمه في التاريخ
ونقتل كل هؤلاء البشر ثم انت ترى ما الذي
يحدث امر عجيب فعلا عجيب بالامس قالوا
بانهم يعطون امانا وترى بان الناس على
المعابر خرجت مطمئنه الى الامان ثم قتلوا
جميعا على المعبر 45 شخص قتلوا وذبحوا
والان نحن نقول بانه فعلا هناك ارهابيون
ولكن من اجل هؤلاء الارهابيين ندمر
المدينه يعني نحرق الغابه كلها سؤال سؤال
هنا ل الدكتور شمس الدين الكيلاني باختصار
شديد
دكتور هل ستخرج حلب بتراثها سلمه هذه
المره بعد كل الحروب التي خيضت عليها و
بشانها بدي احكي شي جملتين فقط باختصار
باختصار سوريا كلها كل الشعب السوري الان
في قرار عمليا مو فقط لتدميره قتله الروس
بداوا حفله قتل الشعب السوري وتصفيه وجوده
حلب بدها تبني نفسها بالمستقبل ولكن دمرت
الان امم مو بس فقط شغله البناء شغله
البشر الاف من البشر العزبات يوم واحد
تصور حال
ابنك يتعرض لهذا القصف
في يقال
الان المنطقه الشرقيه حلب في حوالي 200000
طفل ليش المنطقه الغربيه موهن
اسرى سوريا كلها مسيره وعم
تتسمع في رعب الشعب السوري يهان اشكرك
ويباد وفي قرار الجميع السوريين الان
يعرفوا من وقت اللي دخل البوتين المجرم
هناك في
قرار لمعركه مثل جروز شكرا لك دكتور شمس
الدين الكيلاني الباحث في المركز العربي
للابحاث ودراسه السياسات بالدوحه واشكرك
دكتور رياض نعسان اغا وزير الثقافه السوري
الاسبق والمتحدث باسم الهيئه العليا
للمفاوضات كنت معنا من الرياض مشاهدينا
الملف الثاني من الحصاد مع غاده عويس
وتبحث فيه تعاطي دول كبرى مع اطراف في
الازمه الليبيه تنازع حكومه الوفاق الوطني
شرعيتها